people has named John Legend no John  Legend was morning John Legend though is  this year sexiest man alive these are  the photos check them out the all of me  singer struck a pose for two different  covers of the magazine the 40 year old  said he is excited to have earned the  honor but also said the pressure of  holding the title is quote scary  it's wipe receipt again is having fun  with it guys as one of you of the folks  who follows Chrissy Teigen standard  account like she tweeted an anticipation  of this and I was like what is she  talking about she said it wasn't a baby  she was tweeting in anticipation of this  after the announcement she tweeted it is  all downhill from here and also with the  sexiest man alive just made me a ham  sandwich last night she even shared her  kids reactions for the big news take a  look  miles are you so happy daddy is the  sexiest man alive Luna are you so happy  daddy's the sexiest man alive  [Music]  real hungry me I'll be right back